ich glaube sonst stecken die meisten
gerade gar nicht was ich eigentlich
sagen will also mir hat diese person zum
beispiel schieben um 21.43 dann habe ich
so ein fragezeichen geschickt weil sie
war irgendwie schon die dritte oder
vierte person bist du alex w falls ja
würde deine nummer durch hacker gelegt
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei anderen video ja leute ich habe euch
dieser stuhl halter der nervt mission
ich möchte auch mal so einen gaming
studenten also an die gaming stuhl
firmen erhält war ich heute was geht ich
hoffe euch jetzt gut heute mit einem
wirklich sehr sehr spontan video fest
kann ich wieder anfangen soll als es ist
gestern was echt blöde es passiert ich
habe immer gehofft dass mir so etwas nie
passiert und das ist mir auch noch nie
passiert bis gestern aber dann ist es
mir halt passiert und ich sehe das ganze
aber relativ locker ich meine passiert
halt man kann jetzt nichts gegen machen
wenn es sich nicht verbessert und muss
ich halt einfach meine nummer wechseln
auf jeden fall fange ich einfach mal
kurz an mit der story
ich war gestern mit freunden unterwegs
und hat sich wirklich so auf mein handy
und es kommt vor dass mir so eine person
schreibt und so fragt hier bist du alex
aber eher selten verstehen oder das mich
halt irgendwie anruf den ich nicht kenne
gestern waren wir dann im restaurant und
ich gucke auf mein handy und da waren
sie zwei hot chip sets von fremden
nummern die so gefragt haben ja bist du
alex und ich bin so nicht darauf
eingegangen dann habe ich einen anruf
bekommen wo keiner dran waren und dann
kann man immer mehr leute die mir eine
nachricht über mozart geschrieben haben
das hat meine nummer veröffentlicht
wurde und die jetzt rum geht oder so und
dass sie mich nur vor wahlen sollten
also viele haben geschrieben dass sie
die nummer halt auch wieder löschen und
dann halt mal testen wollten ob es
wirklich die echte nummer ist und mich
halt auch vor waren ja dann habe ich
eine person zurück geschrieben und
gefragt wie kommt das denn wohl woher
hast du meine nummer und sie meinte soja
auf oben ist twitter account also von
simon rummel kennen ja wahrscheinlich
die meisten von euch hat auf youtube
auch glaube ich über zwei millionen
dort wurde halt meine nummer
veröffentlicht und ich dachte hey wieso
er sich ich kenne ihn gar nicht habe gar
keinen kontakt zu ihm hat auch nicht
meine nummer wohl nicht seine nummer
deswegen wie kommt das jetzt zustande
und da meinte sie
ja der account wird gehackt ich kann
euch vielleicht auch mal den chef im
verlauf zeigen und ich weiß auch
mittlerweile warum meine nummer dort ist
was wirklich ein extremer zufall ist und
es ist das ist eigentlich so ein pech
gestern kann auch schon ein video auf
seinem youtube kanal das habe ich mir
dann abends noch angeschaut wir können
ja kurz mal reinschauen welche gerhard
dabei bin das hier ist übrigens mein
neuer account alex dort zu sagen gibt es
jetzt ab und zu abends live streams
dreimal in der woche und dann lade ich
auch ein paar videos suchte ich auf
meinem ersten kanal nicht hochladen
würde
deswegen lohnt sich auf jeden fall da
vorbeizuschauen abonniert den kanals
oben in der beschreibung von neun
minuten kam es noch ein weiteres video
das habe ich jetzt noch nicht gesehen
und wir schauen wir hier kurz rein also
da sagt er meinte ich würde jetzt sagen
mein twitter-konto direkt also falls ihr
auf twitter folgt kein links an auch
wenn es bis jetzt überwiegend so
facebook links sind die jetzt nicht
unbedingt gefährlich sind da stehen nur
informationen drin aber es könnte sein
dass da irgendwelche links zwischendurch
nicht rein wenn dir so also mehr muss
man da ja gar nicht hören also da war
ich mir schon mal sicher gut er hat es
nicht gemacht sondern er wurde gehackt
und dann dachte ich aber btf hat nun der
hacker meine nummer her so was macht ihr
eigentlich gar keinen sinn weil da war
ich jetzt wirklich schon so ein bisschen
panisch wenn ich nicht wüsste woher der
meine nummer hat so als wenn er mich
halt oder man kann ja auch sein dass er
mich komplett direkt hat keine ahnung
man denkt ja dann direkt einmal das
schlimmste hey leute und willkommen zu
einem kleinen update video zu dem thema
ich wurde gehackt entwarnung dazu ich
bin auch da nicht mehr gedeckt und habe
meiner kunst auch zurückbekommen der
youtube beziehungsweise gmail und
twitter support war sehr hilfreich da
wir sehr schnell geholfen innerhalb von
zwölf stunden war alles wieder geregelt
ist schon sich jetzt nicht das ganze
video zu schauen und das muss ich auch
wenn man mal in ruhe machen was aber
auch noch ganz ganz wichtig ist zu sagen
ich gehe gar nicht mal davon aus dass
der beweis dass meine nummer hat zb da
veröffentlicht wurde
also ich will hier niemanden was
vorwerfen
und ich kann auch nur das sagen was mir
diese ganzen leute halt geschrieben
haben kann ich euch auch sofort mal
zeigen wie schon gesagt nur beweise
dafür gibt es halt nicht wirklich ja ich
benutze auch selber eigentlich gar
keinen twitter und hier sollte einfach
wohl dieses foto gewesen sein mit meiner
nummer also ich würd sagen wir schauen
uns einfach mal zusammen und chat
verlauf an von einer person die mir
heute geschrieben hat ich glaube sonst
stecken die meisten gerade gar nicht was
ich eigentlich genau sagen will also mir
hat diese person zum beispiel
geschrieben hype um 21.43 dann habe ich
so ein fragezeichen geschickt weil sie
war irgendwie schon die dritte oder
vierte person bist du alex w falls ja
würde deine nummer durch hacker geliebt
und ich saß da so gedacht okay wie warte
mal wo hast du denn jetzt meine nummer
hier also kommen jetzt gleich tausend
menschen die beschreiben und so werde
ich war echt ich hatte richtig angst und
sie schreibt auf seinem twitter wurde
kurz ein dokument gepostet worüber man
von vielen bekannten personen die daten
herausfinden kann
sorry dass ich dir hier schreibe ich
dachte auch nicht dass das wirklich die
nummer ist falls sie es ist also ich
werde die dann auch direkt wieder
löschen und nicht weiterleiten ich finde
die aktion selber aber dann weißt du es
jetzt immerhin haben aber sicherlich
nicht viele gesehen wäre vielleicht
trotzdem vom vorteil die niemals zu
sechs sind also das habe ich dann auch
gedacht dass das halt nicht viele
gesehen haben weil ich habe direkt auf
einen twitter-account gegangen und dort
war dieses foto nicht mehr was sie mir
geschickt oder was du mir geschickt
hatte aber anscheinend einige der leute
die dann gecheckt haben dass ich das bin
meine nummer irgendwie die klassen
gruppe geschickt und dann kann man sich
ja denken wie das weitergeht
ich habe geschrieben abgas und das
dokument wurde von wem erstellt und weil
ich habe irgendwie gar nicht gecheckt zu
dem zeitpunkt so hacker meine nummer wie
steht das jetzt in verbindung
die heißen unterstrich orbit auf twitter
haben darauf eine menge von links und
dann habe ich so geschrieben habe war
haben die meine nummer wo findet man die
links sie wusste halt auch nicht woher
die meine nummer haben ich bis zu dem
zeitpunkt auch nicht ich hab es dann
allerdings direkt gecheckt und zwar auf
dem twitter-account und eben diesem
dokument das kurz täter veröffentlicht
wurde ist aber wieder gelöscht habe ich
gesagt kannst du mir mal ein link von
ihren twitter schicken hatte mir auch
gemacht das ist hier twitter.com diese
orbit soll ist nichts spannendes
also ist halt irgendwie so ein hacker
verein bekenne ich mich jetzt auch nicht
aus und dann hat sie mir dieses bild
geschickt weiß ich jetzt zum großen teil
eigentlich immer topix mit muss ich ja
dazu geschrieben
da stehst du zum beispiel beim micro
sechs kontakten die haben eine ganze
liste von leuten deren daten die
veröffentlicht haben keine ahnung woher
also ich gehe einfach mal davon aus dass
ich so der einzige youtuber bin der
jetzt da veröffentlicht wurde weil ich
habe jetzt von keinem anderen gehört
oder ich zumindest erbin der am längsten
dort war und wo dann die meisten leute
die nummer halt schnell raus ziehen
konnten das hier ist wohl das foto was
da gepostet wurde und ich habe dann
direkt mirko geschrieben also mehr
korosec ich weiß ich bin natürlich immer
kurz zuvor teilen könnt ja vielleicht
der ein oder andere von euch so von
weniger weil es so eben was davon dass
du gehackt wurde ist weil irgendwie
wurden deine kontakte bei omi gepostet
und er so auch nämlich gerade zum ersten
mal kann ich euch mal zeigen also jetzt
zum ersten mal davon gehört und habe ich
quasi ein dass seine kontakte und er
soja sind mein also sein handy wird wohl
gehackt was allerdings sein altes handy
es hat er noch dazu gesagt weil er viele
kontakte gar nicht merklich zensiert
jetzt auch hier allerdings hatte er auf
unserem alten handy meine aktuelle
nummer 1 gespeichert und das blöde ist
auf diesem ausschnitt ist meine nummer
genau und alex w ja genau in der mitte
und das ist halt mega der mit zufall so
weiter hätten ja auch irgendwelche
anderen youtuber drauf sein können aber
ich bin halt einfach der einzige und
diese hacker haben dann anscheinend auch
noch alex w jetzt markiert hochgeladen
ja und jetzt habe ich den salat
also das ist die story dahinter ich
finde es wirklich heftig so den gestern
abend auch gar nicht klargekommen sogar
her
es geht hier also zusammenfassend lässt
sich sagen ich wurde nicht gehackt aber
andere leute wurden gehackt und dadurch
wurde meine nummer die diese leute haben
veröffentlichen
das ist die story dazu ihr könnt gerne
mal eure meinung in die kommentare
schreiben
also wenn du mir das hier sehen sollte
du weißt wahrscheinlich gar nicht dass
meine nummer da war keine ahnung ich
weiß auch nicht was sie zu sagen sollen
aber so was halt
aber herzlich willkommen zurück leute
ich muss noch kurz was hinzufügen das
ist ja sehr wichtig weil ich mich jetzt
gerade noch mal ein bisschen hingesetzt
habe ein bisschen weiter recherchiert
habe und ich jetzt das ganze nicht so
stehen lassen möchte also erst mal
umgehört in dem neuen video von sich
gesagt dass halt viele daten von
politikern und prominenten
veröffentlicht wurden ob das jetzt da
die von ihm waren oder allgemeinen daten
die halt irgendwie gelegt wurden weiß
ich nicht und das ganze geld gerade auch
extrem durch die medien finde ich echt
krass ich kann mich jetzt also wirklich
so jede große zeitung berichtet darüber
kann ich mich jetzt nicht so dran
erinnern das ist schon mal so krass war
nach einem hacker-angriff auf youtube
vielleicht liegt auf falls keine ahnung
diesen artikel habe ich mir durchgelesen
von t-mobile und und ihr steht da drin
ein hacker die sandte details von
spitzenpolitikern zum beispiel mir und
prominenten veröffentlicht online konnte
sich mit einem youtuber unterhalten der
in der nacht zum freitag kontakt zu dem
hacker hatte was da jetzt stimmt und was
nicht keine ahnung sondern wollen er
hier seit der thomas und jahr älter hat
halt wohl rom ist ritter account gehackt
und aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen und
reichweite und da dann bis ihren
schabernack zu treiben mit irgendwelchen
daten hat aber wohl nichts gelöscht
das ist ja schon mal sein sonst nicht
und ganz wichtig teil der erbeuteten
daten könnte älter sein
teilweise seien die erbeuteten daten
nicht mehr aktuell oder wurden bereits
vor einiger zeit er wollte das soll
darauf hin dass hier über längere zeit
gesammelt wurde wahrscheinlich von
mehreren personen und eventuell auch aus
verschiedenen älteren quellen was ja
auch ganz klar auf die ältere quelle wo
meine handynummer jetzt raus stadt wien
schließt weil das ja markus altes handy
war und er das jetzt schon seit dem jahr
oder so nicht mehr benutzt also haben
die sicherheit wahrscheinlich das ganze
material angesammelt hätten theoretisch
meine handynummer schon viel früher
veröffentlichen können haben sie arbeite
ist irgendwie gemacht also ich finde das
ganze wirklich krass und da jetzt selber
sogleich mit drin zu sein ist natürlich
blöd aber was willst du machen also das
waren jetzt alle infos die ich habe zu
der sache und bin jetzt einfach mal
gespannt wie es weitergeht und wie viele
da habe ich nicht nur bekomme also dass
man euch bitte nicht schreiben wer super
cool und wir sehen uns dann italien
wieder haut rein